quick update from our poll on the David
Pakman show YouTube channel as many of
you no doubt know Andrew yang dropped
out of the presidential campaign after
an abysmal 2.8 percent of the vote on
Tuesday in New Hampshire it was the
right thing to do and yesterday we asked
on our YouTube channel
who should drop out next and
overwhelmingly our audience believes
that it is outgoing Hawaii congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard who should drop out next
the poll was after seeing the results of
Iowa and New Hampshire which Democrats
should drop out of the race next 25,000
of you voted and 42 percent a
significant plurality believe that it is
Tulsi who should drop out next 28% say
Joe Biden should drop 14% say Elizabeth
Warren 13 percent say Tom Styer now I
imagine that there is some satire here
Elizabeth Warren already has delegates
and steyr has none it's hard to argue
Warren should drop out before a Tom
Steyer does although he may actually end
up with more delegates by the time we
get to Super Tuesday because if
Elizabeth Warren gets no delegates in
Nevada and steyr does well in South
Carolina he's polling well there it's
actually conceivable that going into
Super Tuesday
Tom Styer could have roughly the same
number of Delegates or maybe slightly
more then does Elizabeth Warren it is
time for Tulsi to go but I actually
don't really care that much if she stays
in I mean at this point if somebody
wants to donate to her it seems like
burning money go ahead and do it she's
not really getting coverage anymore
she's not at the debates it's like yes
they and I I don't really care one way
or the other but mathematically I don't
see a path for Tulsi to get even a
single delegate steyr at least can say
I'm going to get delegates in South
Carolina probably um I don't see a path
to a single delegate for Tulsi Gabbard
so my question to you is if you have a
mathematical case for Tulsi not being
the next to drop I want to hear from you
I don't want to hear well Tulsi has a
case because she's the only candidate
against the forever Wars that's not a
mathematical argument I want to hear
something that
challenges the idea that Tulsi has zero
delegates and has no path to a single
delegate why should she stay in on that
basis get in touch and let me know do
you feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that there are just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman what blinka studs
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books and condense them into either text
or audio that you can read or listen to
in just 15 minutes and what you get is
all of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to catch and kill by
Ronan Farrow super interesting book
probably already familiar to some in my
audience and a really interesting take
at how Harvey Weinstein and his alleged
transgressions were brought to light
excellent investigative piece blink is
has totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blink Asst
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you